it's a symptom of what's wrong with
society that so much of our effort goes
into uh making things secure if you
imagine what fraction of our economy
goes into computer security safety uh
air security Etc things that we would
not have to do at all if you could trust
each other blockchain may have
advantages um but of course downside is
that its main motive is to uh provide
security which you wouldn't need to
bother about if you could trust people
today we are speaking with uh a man who
is uh I call him the biggest mench in
the Multiverse it is uh Lord Martin Ree
astronomer Royale a friend of the arthy
Clark Center for human imagination uh
longtime influence inspiration and
really in some ways the father of my
field of CMB polarization as I'll
explain as we go on but first today uh
Martin welcome are you in Cambridge
right now I'm atonement Cambridge and uh
great to be with you brown it's great to
to be with you I always cherish our
conversations today we're going to be
talking uh first about your book on the
future uh which came out a couple of
years ago but the reason for this is
that Lord ree was one of the recipients
of the Arthur C Clark Foundation um
Awards recently uh for the future along
with Ted Chang and Fabian Fabiola gianti
of CERN and uh it's was an occasion to
get get some time with him I could not
resist so first of all congratul ation
on winning the Arthur C Clark Foundation
Award thank you very much and that was
about the future and I think your book
is was really kind of a a Cornerstone
theme I read it when it came out I
reread it and uh and I really do want to
talk about it usually uh Lord Martin we
we review the first thing I always say
is I judge all books by their cover and
this cover is perhaps the most sparse
cover I've ever seen so we won't talk
about the cover but I do want to talk
about the title you are known for
provocative titles and in some cases
your titles get changed depending on
where they're printed so first of all
can you explain what is the meaning of
on the future and prospects for Humanity
what drove you to create a book like
this well as you mentioned I did have a
book uh about 15 years ago which I
called our final Century with a question
mark which raised issues about long-term
threats the Publishers cut out a
question mark but when it was published
in America the title was changed to our
final
hour and I interpret that as being that
you guys want instant gratification and
a
reverse in anation title and this was a
more innocuous title but uh the theme of
the book is that um we are in a very
special century and I guess that's what
we'd be discussing before we begin I do
want to mention uh this um honorific
that you maintain which is uh astronomer
Royal and and you once told me and in
fact you you say it in the book but I'm
going to tell it the way you told me
that most of the time people think your
job is to read the queen her
horoscope and I I love that line and I'm
hoping you'll tell me what I am uh but I
but I but I once went to a a horoscope
reader when I was dating my soon to be
wife of uh 14 or so years from now I
should remember that uh but we were
dating and she wanted to see some you
know astrologer and the astrologer asked
me what's your sign and I saidwell you
know I'm a Gemini I think and she said
okay well this is going to happen to you
there's going to be you know
fluctuations in the stock market um
there'll be uncertainty in the Middle
East and uh and then at the end I said
you know what I'm actually born in
September isn't that a Virgo and the
astrologer said yeah but it doesn't
matter your horoscope is the same and I
wonder you talk a little bit about in
the book for the first time I feel like
we're I have a kindred spirit and that
you're kind of um little not
antagonistic towards Carl popper but the
notion of the demarcation hypothesis and
how that has become synonymous with what
is good science I wonder could you speak
a little about your views on papism I
talked to Lenny suskin about a month ago
and he called it the paparazzi and don't
get obsessed with the paparazzi tell me
what are you what are your feelings
about what constitutes science in the
context of astrology astronomy Etc well
I mean I think it's got to be something
which uh is subject to empirical test
and which is Progressive Etc and
astrology isn't because it's a mumbo
jumbo and you can't really test it and
hasn't survived the test of been done um
but um the POA um scenario which of
course has been very popular I mean most
philosophers are unduly contemptuous of
sorry most scientists are unduly
contemptuous of philosophy Hing in
particular was outrageously dismissive
of philosophy completely unjustifiably
um but um the philosophers who
scientists have liked include uh two I
guess in particular um and one of them
is Carl poer and his uh idea was that to
be a scientific statement it's got to be
refutable if you can't refute it and
it's not science and there's something
in that because um to take an example I
mean um reincarnation which is an idea
held by many people but uh there's no
way in which you could refuted to their
satisfaction so that's the reason why
reincarnation is not science um but
reputation is of course an important
part of science but it's not infallible
I mean I quote an example in my book um
that um supposing that the Michaelson
moley experiment that's experiment that
shows that light goes at the same speed
um at any time in the year even though
the Earth is going around um if that had
been done in the um 16th or 17th century
it would have been used to ref shoot
cernus people would say that clearly
through the Earth does not move um and
so that is an example showing how you
can't be convinced of a reputation
unless you're convinced of the um uh
grounding of that particular argument so
uh it's fuzzier than POA tried to
maintain but nonetheless uh he pointed
out that if you can't find any evidence
against a theory and uh reincarnation
example of that uh then it's not really
science yes I want to run by you an
example another example and get your
impressions about it and that is um the
proof that the Earth is not round from
the rening of sunlight at sunset or
equivalently in the cosmic microwave
background uh image or or the
observatory that's behind me in my zoom
background see the very thick optical
density of the atmosphere which is
indicative of a flat planer atmosphere
spere which means that the Earth must be
a flat planer
object so yes and I think and I wanted
to ask you this for a while I've asked
it of Sir Roger Penrose um and uh and
and others and that is about you know
falsification um and and and and popper
that I have noted sort of a an Envy you
know Freud would probably call it a math
mathematician Envy as as as his want and
it's ironic that poer wasn't talking
about cosm ology or astronomy he was
actually a proponent of the steady state
as you know for for some time uh but but
he was he was irritated at astrologers
and even psychoanalysis as you talk talk
about in on the future but um but the
but the impression that I get is that we
physicists are um antagonized or perhaps
uh we are envious of mathematicians
because girdle showed what constitutes
mathematics but there's no equivalent
for what constitutes physics and and I
wonder is that because physics is by
nature provisional and and is subject to
Imperial update I mean Isaac azimoff
once said you know if you think the
Earth is flat you're wrong if you think
the Earth is a perfect sphere you're
also wrong but you're less wrong than if
you think it's flat so I wonder do we
feel as physicists inadequate envious uh
perhaps tension and anxiety because we
can't refute things so easily as say
girdle showed in mathematics well it may
be true but of course uh you're asking
obverse of the most common question
which is physics Envy which many other
scientists have because compared to most
other Sciences which deal with things
more complicated than single atoms and
molecules and um Newtonian gravity
physics is simple and straightforward
and therefore it is easier to get
clear-cut results in physics than in
most other Sciences sub subject matter
of physics is simpler so normally people
say that it's the other subjects are and
of course um the way in which you can
gain confidence in a science even when
it's not one that lends itself to
clear-cut reputations is if a whole set
of
arguments embeds together in a
consistent Story I mean I think if you
look at something like a um continental
drift for instance um play tectonics
that was an idea um and what was
convincing about that was it explained
lots of hither to surprising
disconnected facts they all together and
darwinian evolution is another case
there's a you could refute it I suppose
if you found some um human bones on in
the lower Strat and than dinosaur bones
or something like that so you could
refute it but um most people uh would
say that the strength of Darwinism is
the huge volume of data which it links
together in a consistent way and offers
a framework for interpreting so uh I
think science is a search for patterns
and unification in diverse
data and uh yeah that reminds me I
sometimes joke that my house is so old
that uh there's a nuclear reactor and
it's covered up by some dinosaur bones
and that just blows people's minds but
um speaking of girdle allegedly he
believed until his deathbed According to
some young person who emails me all the
time about the rotating Universe
hypothesis that the Universe uh is
rotating in at least girdle's conception
of the cosmo cosmogeny and and then even
on his deathbed he said that he wondered
is the universe still
rotating and and you must get a lot of
these emails I get a lot of them I was
joking with um with Adam ree uh who uh
was on the podcast a couple of times
this year and I said you know Adam I get
all these emails you know as I'm sure
you do Einstein was wrong I can prove it
if you help me with the maths because
I'm not so good at maths uh but if you
help me I'll share a portion of the
Nobel Prize with you I get those emails
and Adam said yeah how do you think I
got my Nobel
Prize so what do you make of the fact
that there are so many people that are
so interested in proving you know
Stephen Hawking right or wrong or
proving Einstein but no one really comes
up and says I think boltzman was wrong
and or Maxwell was wrong and Maxwell was
actually wrong about many things but um
but nobody seems they always seem to
want to take down Einstein what is that
compulsion that people have in in I mean
I think you know they want to attack the
biggest targets don't they and Einstein
is one but Darwin's one and but I also
have had letters from people saying
Newton was wrong that because I was head
of Newton's college and presid sideway
agre so there people are slightly more
original who want to go back and prove
Newton wrong not M to show Einstein was
wrong but of course showing Darwin was
wrong is of course so much more popular
foro yes of course you know of course
Newton was wrong uh in some ways but uh
he he hasn't retracted his uh some of
his blunders in alchemy and in uh
Theology and I guess that brings me to
another point I often find that um the
most famous scientist on Earth right now
to the extent that anybody knows a
scientist um they might think that
Stephen Hawkin Hawkins that I usually
say I want to write to you about Stephen
Hawkins and I say first you have to
spell name right uh but or the Nobel
Prize with an l e at the end uh but I
want to know um you know when people
think about um theories or the or
scientists rather they think about
theorists they think about Brian Green
they think about Mitch okaku Stephen
Hawking uh they might think about you um
why is it that there's such an over
appreciation in my opinion an
overabundance of of kind of association
with scientist as being theorist such as
your off well I suppose they like to
think of the idea of the the great mind
understanding the universe Etc but of
course it is um a very misleading view
of science because I mean uh um if we
look at our science um then it's owed at
least
95% to advances in instrumentation isn't
it um um we're no wise than Aristotle
was in fact we're less wise than he was
and the only reason we made progress is
by having better data really and uh uh
and so it's it's a subject which is led
by observation and the observations only
improve because of better um instruments
and now better comp computations as well
so um the the armchair theorist um of
course gets exaggerated a claim because
there are very few um branch of science
where he or she makes a role comparable
to that of the
experiment and I'm curious you said that
we are less wise than arist I I feel
like I don't know something that
Aristotle said uh from heavy bodies fall
faster than light bodies to you know
Notions about the steadiness of the
universe's endurance um I don't know a
single physical principle that he was
right about he was brilliant when it
came to philosophy and and social psych
no but I'm saying that he was he wasn't
he wasn't right but as an intellect of
range um he was clearly very high IQ
indeed yes higher than us my thumb is
very busy right now holding up good old
Albert but if yours is free please go
ahead and hit that like button and don't
forget to subscribe it really helps us
with the algorithm and that brings me to
another question tomorrow night I'll be
speaking with giant narar who's uh one a
wonderful figure and I'm sure did you
overlap with giant and Fred H was about
three or four years ahead of me but of
course I I did overlap with him he was
uh working with Fred H um uh as a
postdoc when I was a graduate student
and of course I've seen him ever since
and in fact I um I I did um a zoom
public lecture to Yuka in Puna which he
set up just a month ago oh wonderful oh
well I'll send you his uh send him your
regards and vice versa after I talked to
him but I'm curious he still maintains
in aspects of the steady state theor the
Quasi steady state theories veracity and
it brings me to my next question that
you know I've seen a lot of times and
you know from being one of my most
prominent endorsers of my book losing
the Nobel Prize that you know we've had
to retract many experimental results
that achieve great great notoriety and
great public attention I always joke
that the announcement occurs on you know
above the fold uh on page one of the New
York Times or or the San Diego Union
Tribune here and uh but then the
retraction if it's ever published occurs
you know on the page 17b of the Saturday
Morning Edition that nobody he reads um
and so I've seen a lot of experiments
retracted I have yet to see a theory
retracted you know just fully divor even
Jeff Burbage who I have the honor of
having his office here at UC San Diego
you know him very well and he was um and
he was he was the holder of my office
before I moved in after his uh death in
2010 but um but he went to his grave
believing in the in the veracity of the
St State Theory too so what what is it
about theories that come so um so
endeared you know to their to their
conjecture that and you you've had many
of these instances of creating theories
so first what is it about a theory that
holds such permanence in the heart of
his or her of its creator I think what
you're saying is one category of person
is is like that um and uh and they they
do get obsessed with with the theory and
indeed an experimentor who spent 10
years building an instrument um is going
to probably have exaggerated feeling for
the importance of what it will discover
otherwise it would be motivated so it's
not surprising that people get committed
to a theory and of course back plank
famously said that um theories survive
until all their proponents die off right
true of some of them um but people do
change but it is very interesting
because um if I mention someone else my
PhD advisor was Dennis Sharma and he he
was someone who um uh he he
was the um most prominent believer in
the steady St Theory apart from its Fe
inventors bondy golden ho invent it and
he was a great supporter of it when I
started in 1964 as a graduate student he
was a believer in the stady state theory
yes and I think I helped to talk him out
of it because one of my student papers
was with him which was some the New
Evidence against steady state um but he
was someone who had to believe something
strongly in order to be motivated to
work on it he's like a lawyer and he
would have this so what do we say if
they find that you know Etc so he had to
be committed um but if I look at my own
attitude I think I'm genuinely not like
that at all I'm quite happy to work at
the same time on two contradictory
theories on the grounds that I want to
know the
answer and by running the two horses
against each other and seeing if one
stumbles then that's the way to decide
which is the best so um I'm very happy
because I want to know the answer um to
explore two theories that's enough
motivation for me to know the answer
whereas there were some people and
Dennis sh's an example had to believe
that something was almost certainly
correct in order to follow up its
consequences and as you say th those
who've got a great commitment to Theory
are um going to be those who are reluct
to give it up and if we go back to
Nika he was a student of Fred Hil and
and uh Fred Hy actually um he he he was
such an inventive man he had lots of
theories and he didn't really have all
that much stake in any one of them I
don't think so um he he he enjoyed the
debate and there was another debate
going on um at this time which was the
first evidence again steady state which
came before the micro background um from
the um distribution um of the um radio
sources quazar and um Martin riy who was
a radio radio astronomer built an
infometer and he showed evidence that
there were
more of these exploding galaxies as well
which Now call quazars um far away than
there are nearby implying that there
were more in the past than there are now
um and this would be inconsistent with
steady state because at all times the
universe you look the same whereas it is
consistent with the evolving universe
and um uh there was a long debate
between uh Hil and riy he's got a lot of
public interest in the UK um but it was
interesting because um H was someone who
enjoyed debate and it uh um and he
didn't get upset by it whereas riy got
really really upset if his work was
criticized and to be fair he was right
yeah um but the point was that he'd
actually built this the world's first um
ineter using App censis techniques and
he' built the thing himself and worked
for years and years and so he got a huge
investment in this project so it's not
surprising that he was uh um going to be
rather committed to its results and uh
to have them sort of uh disparaged by an
armare theorist was upsetting for him
yeah and of course he in some ways had a
a later laugh although maybe not the
last laugh with the recipient of the
Nobel Prize and was he the astronomer
Royal I forgot he was for a time because
the history of that job is that until
196 it was the person who ran the
greenish Observatory yes which was a
real job but then when when that became
a museum um and people started going to
Hawaii and Chile to do observations they
kept the title but kept it as an honory
title and indeed Martin riy was hold of
that title yeah I believe Margaret
Burbage my late colleague here at UC San
Diego was she was director of rgl the
Royal granch Observatory but she wasn't
astronomer um and then that caused her
in some ways beneficially for me to come
to San Diego eventually and start my
department so thank the uh thank the uh
astronomer Royal recipients or deciders
for that for me if you will um so just
one last thing about you know these
these theories I wonder just speculating
you know when I build an experiment it's
not me building the experiment we
literally have 300 people working on the
Simon's Observatory and pictured behind
me whereas a theory can be done by one
or two people and so it's much more
associated with one's identity I would
say I mean I bleed and I sweat and I cry
over all my experiments but you know if
it's a it has to be a collaborative
Endeavor it's too big to be done
individually whereas I think you can
still do Theory today and I want to
Circle back in a in a 2018 interview you
said one of your um character traits
which I take is a good trait is is that
you're impatient and you like to
multitask in the sense that you like to
work on many different things at once uh
and some sense you remind me of uh Jim
Simons and that you like to headed your
headed your risk your downside risk and
of course that's a lot of what this book
on the future is about we'll get to that
in just a second it's a little hard to
see uh but um but getting back to uh I
want to go back to
1968 uh when you came up with the idea
that the Universe might be po the CNB
might be polarized and I want to remind
our listeners and viewers that this is
only 3 years after the discovery of the
cosmic micro background itself and
at this point the anisotropies of the
microwave background had not been
understood or measured in any way even
the dipole had not been measured and
here was Lord Reese as I believe it was
part of was it part of your PhD thesis
Martin that was a postto as a post so
you conjecture that it might be
polarized if the universe were behaving
in an interesting way and because
sometimes I feel like even incorrect
theories can provide uh very important
um touchstones for experimentalist like
myself to pursue even though the
ultimately the cause of the polarization
in your model was not uh was not the
correct one in that I believe you
ascribed a potential polarization to an
anisotropic expansion of the universe
expanding as a quadripole distribution
that um with a quadripolar asymmetry in
its expansion rate I believe technically
that that would produce a uh the
conditions necessary for polarization we
now know that's not what causes the
polarization but nevertheless it wasn't
discovered for another 32 years so you
spoke once about you know kind of being
impatient and then moving on so I want
to say is there a value in theories that
ultimately might not be right but they
can be used to impel experimentalists
like me I think so and just to expand a
bit on that the reason I did this was
that there was a great deal of interest
at that time in anisotropic models where
the expansion was fast in faster in One
Direction than in correction and there
was something called the mix master
Universe which expanded fast one way
than the other and the motive for this
uh in the late 60s um was um provided by
Charlie misner who's um theorist at
Maryland and the argument was it it's
what's called a horizon problem that um
different parts of the universe in the
standard model don't causally connect
early on and this is a one of the things
that the inflationary idea solved 20
years later
but over in the UK we were aware of the
Horizon problem 10 years at least before
Alan Goose was and the arguments being
discussed then were that the um
expansion may be anot Tropic and the
Russians had ideas like this and so um I
was familiar with these models for anop
universes and in those models it's
fairly easy to see um that the radiation
will be polarized um and and then I said
at the at the end of my paper that uh
you get this for other kinds of
variation but I was only thinking at
that time um of these models where the
entire Hub expansion was faster in some
directions than others yeah and I wonder
even in the Quasi stady State cosmology
they had this notion of the Seafield
which you know continually created
matter uh so as to preserve the density
and the overall appearance which I
remember Jeff Burbage talking to me
about was you know pre-aging some
Notions of the constancy of of of dark
energy uh I disputed that I I do take a
little credit because once I gave a talk
about our experiment polar bear which is
a precursor to the Simons array and Jeff
was in the audience and usually when a
cosmologist would come to speak here at
UC San Diego Jeff would kind of harumph
and say cosmology really you know and
and his great booming British Lion voice
uh but this time I showed a picture of
our detectors and he said and and I
couldn't believe this he said wow that
is really kill and I just thought you
know he's gone Californian I mean to
talk like a surfer but there was
something about experiment that he
really loved and and and and of course
he he wasn't an observer he was he was a
theorist Margaret was The Observer of
the duo and she was a Titanic figure in
astronomy uh and you know as you kind of
hinted to before plank uh about you know
theories advancing he said something
also you know Theory or science advances
one funeral at a time uh and yet I still
believe that there are valuable
contributions even in these things like
narla car and and so forth but the the
problem is somebody needs to tap them on
the shoulder so to speak and say you
have this amazing gifted mind but I
think it could be used in other
directions and and I want to turn to
that now I've done a lot of sorry were
you gonna say something no I was going
to say I mean uh going back to narik car
um uh H was very keen and uh the thing
is very sad yeah was that um narar was
almost complete contemporary of of
Hawking and Carter yeah
Etc in the same building and Fred H
never appreciated the work which Hawking
and Carter were doing classic work on
black holes um and narika had such great
loyalty to Fred Hy that he never got
involved in this whereas he was would
have been fully able to do uh important
work in the native black holes you know
but whereas all the other young people
followed the lead of Roger Penrose and
used his techniques to explore black
holes and this was all done in the late
60s um with the this group in Cambridge
playing a big role um Nika I think out
of loyalty to Fred never got involved
yeah and if you look at his later books
he talks about um cosmology and he talks
about the micro background and all that
but he has a chapter at the end where he
will feel out of loyalty he's got to put
in a chapter on steady state universe
yes I know I'm going to talk to him
about that very issue uh tomorrow when
he comes on the show and yes there
always you know there problems and
speculations on cosmology one of his
more recent books and you know some of
it uh it's It's Curious it's it's it's
um it's novel to hear at least from my
perspective that Hoy was at least maybe
less loyal or less passionate because I
always had the impression that he was
more embittered than than narar but it
but it sounds like and I'll talk to to
Giant about this tomorrow but but the
question of you know whether or not you
know loyalty to a theory and loyalty to
an idea and that takes me to my next
question about the proliferation of
theories of everything so I've had a lot
of conversations over the last six
months with folks like Steven Wolfram
Eric Weinstein I'm gonna be speaking
with h with Julian Barbour as well as
Garrett leasy and others with new claim
new theories of everything as well as um
you know people that are in more
traditional Fields like I to Sheldon
glashow and I've talked to Frank wilch
about this provocative question I like
to pose to my honored guests or my the
guests that honor me I don't know I do
honor you uh but the point is uh do we
need a theory of everything and the
reason hearkens back to what you just
mentioned about about Hawking and and
Penrose and I talk I asked this of Sir
Roger as well I said I always find that
it's kind of like this uro burus the
snake that eats its own tail we say we
need a theory of quantum gravity because
we don't understand the properties of
singularities at the center of black
holes or perhaps The Singularity at the
origin of time uh itself in the
so-called big bang and the question of
you know these things must be unified
because we need a theory of gravity
that's quantized because we can't
understand singularities uh otherwise
now going back to our earlier point
about about um falsification or maybe
even
empiricism we can't ever access the
singularity at the core of a black hole
we don't know if it's real we don't know
its entity we don't know its nature its
properties it's it's firewalled off
literally I mentioned this to Lenny
suskin H and he sort of agreed that the
actually to him the most interesting
part of the black hole is not the
singularity it's the event horizon or
what he calls the stretched Horizon and
then talking to Sir Roger similarly
about black holes but also about the
origin of the universe which you know
I'm sure he doesn't believe in a a
Quantum you know B bing bang a
singularity in time and neither does my
friend and your friend uh Paul
steinhardt so my question is if God I
know you don't believe you don't
actively affirm a belief in God but God
hands me a letter you know and says
Brian read this to Lord Martin and it
says there was no singular Big Bang it's
more complicated than that it's either
classical or eons or or what have you or
bouncing and um and then they also say
there is no way to observe God says you
can't observe what's happening at the
center of a black hole so in that case
if you knew there were no real examples
that we could ever probe would you still
say we need a theory of everything you
wrong in assuming we could never have
any evidence for it because um it's
clear as you say that uh we could
understand the Big Bang better if we
could understand context where clearly
gravity is important and quantum theory
is important things very high density
Etc um now uh the problem is we can't do
experiments um in the regimes but if we
in principle had a theory which could
describe the conditions rise at the
beginning of the universe and inside a
black hole and if that same
Theory predicted the masses all the
elementary particles and the relative
strengths and all the fundamental
numbers of physics then we'd know there
was something in it and it's a heresy to
think that you have to be able to test
all the consquence of theory you have to
be able to test enough consequences to
get confidence in it and then you take
Serious predictions when you can't
observe so to go back to black holes we
take what Einstein's theory says about
the inside of a black hole seriously
even though we can't observe it there
because we've been able to verify
Einstein's theory in many other
contexts outside the black hole and so
likewise we could have a theory um uh
which does give us a b deep insight into
the big bang and unification and
incidentally into dark energy which I
think is going to need similar sort of
theory um and we could gain confidence
in it if it manages to explain the
standard model and all the arbitary
numbers in that if it gives formul for
those then that'll be a huge achievement
and we take the theory seriously but um
having said all that um the the phrase
Theory of Everything is a very
unfortunate phrase which what we been
talking about now and what I'm saying we
would like to have is a the it unifies
the four forces of nature as it were
unifies the gravity for the very large
with the very small and so in or borus
when the snake eat his tail it can cope
with
that that J position that's right but of
course uh qu the of everything is Mis
misleading because if you think of all
the other
Sciences biology chemistry everything
else um none of them are held up to the
slightest
extent by the lack of this Theory right
quantum theory even Nuclear Physics is
pretty irrelevant to to to chemists and
and biologists and so the main
challenges in science or some of the
main challenges in science are the
challenges of complexity biological
World um and uh uh and so even if we
accept that everything is as Luci fic as
equation Etc that's not the way we
understand them and I think this sort of
um uh extreme reductionism is very
misleading if let me give one example of
this um of course lots of people think
that living things have special vitalism
and all that you know un Mr Roger and
steuart Hammer off have this yes yes um
but the main point is that every every
science uh when you go from physics to
chemistry to cell biology to organisms
um all the way up to societies um each
science at each level has its own
irreducible Concepts and let me take a
simple example it doesn't involve
vitalism it's less controversial fluid
mechanics it's a well- defined subject
okay the
um where the concepts are turbulence
viscosity Etc and you work out and
understand how waves break and all all
that and when flows go unstable and it's
a serious subject and all that but the
people who work on that subject they
treat the liquid the water as a
fluid Continuum they don't care it's
H2O and even if you had a massive
computer which could solve sur's
equation for 10 to the 30th atoms in in
in a flowing stream then that solution
wouldn't give you any insight the inside
comes from the level and so um as you go
one step up from Atomic physics you get
things like
mechanics which are scientist of their
own right which have their own Concepts
and no one
denies that um uh flow of water is a
solution toal equation but it's not
helpful to be able to do that even you
can solve the equation and of course
most would say that's true of living
things as well yeah I mean there's a
famous quote or phrase attributed to
direct you know he said something like
you know my equation explains most of
chemistry and no most of uh all of
chemistry and most of biology or and I
always thought you know in nth grade
biology class you know if I say let me
let me get the relativist extraordinary
equation out and solve it so I can
dissect this
frog some big problems all the Frog
would have bigger problems it doesn't
give us any insight that's right yes
it's it's true but not useful uh I want
to give um a little break to recognize
Our Guest Lord Martin Reese author of
many books including just six numbers on
the future final hour SL Century
whichever comes first I guess uh and
want to thank my listeners and viewers I
want to encourage you to like And
subscribe and and comment on the video
and uh please leave a review on iTunes
wherever you're listening to this uh so
that we can continue to get great guests
like Lord Martin Ree who just having
such a ball with this is such a a
wonderful delicious treat uh for me so
uh like going back to this this question
of of you know complexity and things
that are complicated so so to speak I I
always make the distinction like getting
a you know a grain uh putting a grain of
sand on a pile you know that's
complexity but it's not really
complicated you can describe it in a
very short amount of text and and you go
through and here this Russian gentleman
whose Name Escapes me right now but he
has he has a a rubric or a way of
delineating and calculating complexity
as the shortest computer code needed to
describe that system so a system of 10
to the you know 28 particles in this
giant sand piles very you know a lot of
particles but there the underlying
forces as as as as you were just saying
uh Lord Martin are very simple to
understand and yet we have examples of
potential theories of everything for
example Steven wolfram's is very
reminiscent of The Game of Life which
you talk about as being simple in some
sense but you know having exhibiting
complexity almost reminiscent of life
but I wonder is maybe and I asked
Stephen about this and I confess I
didn't fully understand answer but I
said well if it's truly a Theory of
Everything does that mean it's going to
get out um you know Bells inequality is
it going to get out you know epr is it
going to get out um you know collapse of
the wave function or is it going to
unify su2 with with su3 and U Want what
is it going to do and and he said yes I
don't understand how something that is
like cellular automata like The Game of
Life can exhibit the principles that
that originate these things and and I
want to take you back to um to these
earlier kinds of of of suppositions
about the Multiverse and how the
universe could begin and they always
start with the laws of physics and the
question I have is where do those come
from in in these in these models is it
necessary for a theory of everything to
explain you know bootstrap how it came
about or is that asking too much as we
don't do a biology as you said well I
mean some people would like to be able
to show that our univ is uniquely
self-consistent in a way and that the uh
the laws um constrain it in such a way
if we almost predict the way it is some
people I think maybe Roger Penrose think
that's true but I mean I think what
wolam is doing it's not conceptually
different from what everyone thinks
which is that very very complex things
like animals um can be produced by
simple simple laws um that's all that
Conway was doing with his game of life
he pointed you can't get surprising
complexity by um uh iterating very
simple laws and that's qualitatively the
same as what happens in in most of
chemistry isn't it um whether um Wolf's
um Theory does incorporate quantum
theory completely I don't know it may be
a different Theory so and now going
through uh your book I noted um well
first of all I want to ask you are you a
pessimistic Optimist or an optimistic
pess
well I mean I think I would say I'm a
optimist about the power of
Technology but a pessimist about
politics and human nature uh in that I I
think the gap between what um technology
would allow us to do and what'll
actually happen is getting wider and
wider and that's indictment of our
ethics and of our politics and uh do you
feel we're there's any hope for out out
uh overcoming this or as Carl Sean said
you know it's dangerous to have a
society whose technological capacity
exceeds its wisdom and and how to use
that technology well it is dangerous and
uh Carl said that and HD Wells said that
um the sense is going to be a race
between education and catastrophe and
that's that's true um so uh I I don't
know how it would pan out um but uh the
world is getting much more difficult to
govern
obviously connected I always used to
joke and I I think I asked this of Sir
Roger penro was the first time I talked
to him but um if somebody oh no I asked
this of Freeman Dyson uh that's right
and I said Freeman if somebody because
he was kind of a contrarian as you know
and I said uh you know if somebody tells
you I've got good news and bad news
which do you want to hear first and his
answer was kind of surprising but I want
to know first from you I don't want to
bias the experiment so if I come up to
you say Lord Martin I've got good news
and I've got bad news which do you want
to hear first I think I want to hear the
bad news first I think he did too I
think he viewed uh wanting to minimize
the number of surprises but also have
the extra time to deal with the
consequences of the bad
news um what about like uh uh somebody
says uh Lord Martin we've got this
wonderful movie you got to see it
because at the end you know they want to
spoil it for you do you want to know
that do you want to know the spoil or do
you want to have the surprise yourself
but it's a movie I want the surprise
okay but if it's a stock market I assume
you'd like to know the
inside um so getting back a little bit
to um to you know Theory versus
experiment which you know is something
that we explore a lot on the into the
impossible podcast I have this notion
that you know Theory and even theorists
are abundant and uh whereas experiments
are extremely hard to do you talk about
the LHC in this book you talk a little
bit about the super collider you know
which is canceled and I brought this up
to Barry barish I said Barry it was good
thing for you that the super collider
was canceled because he was working as
one of the leaders of the super
conducting super collider in 1993 was
cancelled and uh it ended up putting him
on a path to go to work for on ligo
whereas if he had where he eventually
won a third share of the Nobel Prize in
2017 and and yet if he had stayed with
the super collider and they had
discovered the higs that we know for
sure that he wouldn't have won the Nobel
Prize because no experimentalist got any
share in the Nobel Prize for that year
so I said it was good for you and he
said I don't like to play games like
that and we we moved on to other topics
but I want to ask you when do you when
do you stop a theory in other words I
know sort of that we lose uh we win in
experimental physics such as the cosmic
microwave background we win very slowly
with time we only win as the square root
of time and in that we have to take four
times as much data four many four times
as many years to get a 2X Improvement on
the signal to noise when do you know
when to turn off a theory or turn off an
experiment is there any kind of rubric
that you can help us with to make these
decisions because they're only getting
more and more complex expensive and
demanding of resources most of which
being the intellect of young people what
I mean I think in terms of experiments
um you know the followup to the LHC is
going to be delayed by I would guess two
decades we don't know um and that's
because people realize that there are
other techniques of ligo and underwater
Nutri experiments and all these things
which can do exciting science um in
related areas much more cheaply um so so
I think uh experiments uh do get more
and more expensive and at some stage you
have to jump off and do something else
but of course theory is very cheap you
just need to to to feed someone and then
they can go and coming up with with
theories and I think uh um there's a
question of whether um if you're a
theorist um do you want to um work on
some popular Theory um or do you want to
strike out and come up with your own
Theory and of course um I think we're
seeing a tendency now um that uh more
people are coming up with sort of rather
more Barac and exotic theories um that's
because um after all I mean string
theory is 40 years old now um
and it's not clear it's on the right
lines or progressing so there a lot of
young people in uh that sort of field
and they want to do something
distinctive and different uh so what
happens is you get a a variety of rather
Barack variants of any theory that are
going to be developed and this is just
psychology people want to make their
Mark Etc but uh um I think it's not very
satisfaction if you have a theory and no
one else takes it seriously at all but
it's also unhealthy if there's a
bandwagon effect and too many people are
working on a particular Theory and I
think that's certainly was true of
string theory 10 or 20 years ago it's
perhaps somewhat less true now towards
the conclusion of the book you make a
very provocative statement in some sense
about where scientists uh should fit in
and I want to push back provocatively as
well uh so you say that physicists don't
get better with age they burn out and
first of all I think there is kind of a
misconception that um that you know you
do your best work by age 30 that may be
true in mathematics um and I T this
conversation with Jim Simons about this
uh as well as others but in experimental
physics you only get better in other
words talking to Barry barish he has
brilliant ideas that will benefit the
Simon Observatory and and we recruit
people Elder States men and women in
this we actually have a committee of the
most distinguished men and women on
earth in my opinion some very young and
some older and uh and in experiment at
least I feel that this statement is not
true that scientists do get better with
age it's just maybe they're not as
creative qu I don't think I I don't
think I denied that I said that um what
can go wrong is if the old ones um don't
stick to what they're good at but go
into some new field and uh and want
think of Shockley and Fred Hy people
like that who who go into a field they
didn't know anything about and the
reason for that is that they're still
scientifically motivated they want to
understand the world but they don't any
longer get satisfaction from continuing
on a plateau doing the work they're good
at and benefit from their experience
they want to do something something new
and they overreach themselves I do say
that if people are happy to go on on a
plateau and deepen their experience that
that's that's fine yeah so you do say
they won't get better in their theories
and I do POS a contrast between
mathematical physicist Etc and say
composers because for most for many
composers anyway they're last works are
their greatest that's right where on any
scientists of whom you'd say that and
the difference is because if you're a
composer you're influenced by musical
styles when you're young but thereafter
it can be just internal development
where science is an inherently social
activity and uh you can't uh stay up to
speed in science unless you're a able to
absorb new techniques and new ideas and
that's what we become less Adept at as
we get older so I think that's that's a
difference but uh if you stick with what
you're good at then then you can at
least stay on the plateau even though
you may not get the high peaks yeah I
want to yeah just Echo that and it is
true you certainly said that eminent and
elderly scientists get shielded and I'll
come back to that in just one second but
you made me think of this thing I've
I've been thinking about with regard to
of all things estate planning you know
which is which is not as as um unicent
as it might sound but just that um many
things in life are benefit from what
Albert Einstein reportedly called the
greatest invention of the human mind
namely compound interest so one of those
I had a guest on Bill Perkins a few
months about a month ago and he was
saying that you want to accumulate
memories just like money because your
memories go grow and compound you know
with with time so the earlier you make a
memory the more time it has to grow and
I feel like that's also true with many
things but including at least the only
discipline I'm familiar with which is
experimental science that you kind of
compound oh I've seen that problem with
this type of electrical conductor and we
need to use this because it's going to
behave better at high altitudes and you
do compound and just like compound
interest you know the last doubling
period is is equal to everything that
came before it uh and that might be why
composers their last work is their best
because they're basically doubling in
their last work everything that they've
done up until that point um is that
really true for many scientists I'm only
thinking about experimental scientists I
think that the the point I was trying to
make is that experimental scientists
benefit from wisdom and age you look at
David Wilkinson who was doing great work
up until literally the day he died but
but then you look at theorists and you
look at uh some theorists and yes they
tend to be doing the same thing they
were doing when they're 40 you know it
has to it has to have some interest rate
associated with it or it doesn't improve
right um but just like losing weight if
you want to lose weight um you know 10
lbs or 5 kilos in a year and you do so a
1% loss per day you know the first three
months you're going to lose less than
you know a quarter of a kilo or
something that you could undo by
drinking one glass of soda so U so it's
very slow and and and it sneaks up on
you and just like you talk about
exponential effects in here the climate
crisis Etc which which hopefully we'll
get to in the remaining minutes that we
have but um but I want to just run a
provocative idea by you and that is um
that I think after a scientist gets to
be a certain age uh that maybe their
best contributions could be teaching and
that could free up the younger
researchers uh you know younger than me
I'm not arguing on my behalf I'm I'm
already almost 50 so that uh that won't
apply to me but you talk about this this
problem of researchers not getting their
first grant until they're 40 and
starting their own you know and by that
time in Years Gone by that would be
towards the end of their career so my
provocative thing is that we should only
have theorist teaching uh because they
certainly know all the class they how to
teach you know Quantum electrodynamics
as well as I do um and maybe better but
you know their work is less dependent on
on getting grants and and and and
proposing original research to go out
and I once proposed this to my colleague
Kim gist and he said I'll fight you if
you like he was gonna have a fist fight
with me because he's a theorist and and
I wonder how do you feel about this
provocative idea that that we basically
have the theorist in physics I don't
know about other fields for them to
solve but get these older people that
are that are distinguished and brilliant
but they're not as uh it's not as
critical to them to be out in the field
or collecting research data as it is for
a younger person than me well I mean I
think uh that's one solution but but I
think there are inherent problems which
I address my book um with Academia now
and uh I wrot an article recently for a
British magazine and you know the editor
makes up the title and the title they
gave me was why I'm glad I'm not a young
academic because what I was saying was
that um uh it's attractive than it used
to be when I when I was starting and
this is not not the case I mean um the
the worst situation is biomedical
Sciences in America that's where there
was a report uh that you get your first
grant the NIH when you're 42 or 43 um
and um uh to take an example um the uh
one of members of that committee um to
the um ex president of Princeton told me
that she um um about my age and she got
got a PhD in three years then a postto
for three more years and then got a
grant to set up her own lab now that's
not possible because the demography is
so different back back in the 1970s the
number of people was going up very far
so so the young outnumbered the old and
there's quick promotion and um obviously
we can't have continued exponential
growth but I do think that it's going to
have the
consequence for academics is very bad
and that's that the most ambitious and
flexible
people won't go into Academia or
research um there'll always be the
nerdish element people like me who will
go into Academia um and uh and pursue
some Obsession Etc but Academia needs to
get its share of flexible talented
people who want to feel they've achieved
something on their own by their 30s and
that was possible in Academia um 50
years ago but it's much harder now um
given that um the numbers are stagnant
now and is aggravated by the fact that
in America you don't have a retiring age
that makes it far worse actually because
people in their 70s are soaking up lots
of the money um but it's going to be bad
and what this is going to mean I think
and I mentioned this in my book is that
um there will be a stagnation perhaps
within Academia and perhaps it be
Resurgence of the independent scientist
because in 19th century you know Darwin
and Lord Ry and people like that were
great men but they weren't an
institution they had the resources they
did their own stuff and of course we
know there are people now um who make a
lot of money by the time they're 40 and
they've got scientific expertise and I
think there may be more of those people
we know a few of them but I there be
more um who um uh do very serious
science um and so things will become per
perhaps like the 19th century when the
science is no longer done in
universities simply because um it's a
very hard SLO in University um to to get
to a position where you have uh
Independence Universe could change to do
this and there's a row for government
labs and things like that in in some
areas but I think we do have to bear in
mind that if you have a sort of slow
promotion and uh people have to fill in
lots of forms to get grants before they
could do anything you're going to deter
the people you most want to keep in and
you a lot about in the book about the
potential for a pandemic um you know to
to strike and the vulnerabilities that
we have let's turn to the to the book a
little bit more in detail now I I found
it so delightful of course we're talking
with Lord Martin Ree author of on the
future and many other books uh including
uh our Cosmic habitat just six numbers
our final hour SL Century again
whichever comes first um so I I just
devoured this book I've got every page
is highlighted so it's kind of I lose
contrast every now and then but you you
say here on page 77 pandemics are an
everpresent natural threat and obviously
uh you know this has crippled a lot of
things in the world but and the human
tragedy we have to say that is and
believe that uh it's been it's been
unbearable in some ways um but uh does
it present us with opportunities you
were just talking about opportunities
for people that are technologically
minded Etc um I found you know that I've
been able to cancel lot of inperson
meetings and and I've been having uh to
spend more time looking at data rather
than you know turning screwdrivers uh
might that have a benefit you know five
years down the road again ignoring the
awful human consequences do you see any
bright spot you know coid dividends well
I think it will be in that sense I think
we've learned that a lot of the travel
we've done is unnecessary um and uh we
we can work more efficiently Etc so um I
think we're not going to go back to the
old normal we're going to go back to a
different one um but we could have
learned those lessons without having a
pandemic couldn't we we don't need we
could have learned them already and we
probably would but we learn those
lessons more quickly I think than we
would have done before and you talk
about the vaccine and how um you know
this is it's it's really amaz I want to
know who who told you about the you know
were you in Wuhan a few years ago
uh um but you talk about you know the
instantaneous for the vaccine that could
be transmitted around the world and of
course a lot of things have gotten
better and tracing and so forth one
thing was kind of provocative that I uh
must say I was surprised by towards the
end you spoke uh relatively negatively I
would say about um about things like
blockchain and Bitcoin is basically you
know you you you said that they don't
really serve a useful purpose Etc do you
still believe that because I can think
of some ways that we could use
blockchain or or Bitcoin even in the
context of you know the virus and and
safeguards Etc have has your opinion
changed or if not why do you feel that
that blockchain is essentially has
negative implications for uh for society
it's a symptom of what's wrong with
society that so much of our effort goes
into uh making things secure you if you
imagine what fraction of our economy
goes into computer security safety uh
air security Etc things that we would
not have to do at all if you could trust
each other of course realize how much of
the economy is unproductive and of
course if you think of the economy in
general then quite a large fra of the
financial sector is is unproductive it's
creaming off money from the rest of us
and not producing anything so I think
the way people work and the uh relative
import different Industries um is
certainly far from optimal and uh um I
don't about block chain may have
advantages um but of course the downside
is that its main motive is to uh um
provide security which you wouldn't need
to bother about if you could trust
people right but of course you know this
from your association with Cambridge and
Isaac Newton that you know Isaac Newton
was Master of the mint and one of the
most vexing problems that he solved was
the problem of coin clipping uh did he
did so very ingeniously by putting
ridges on coins of of precious metal I
find it very very uh very um kind of
humorous almost that we still nowadays
have these ridges on the edges of
quarters which used to be a quarter
ounce of silver in America and now are
like zinc and tin and aluminum you know
and they have no value whatsoever but we
still have these fluted or ridged edges
that Isaac Newton uh provided really
solved an age-old problem uh involving
trust and counterfeiting where coins
would be shaved down and the scrapings
would then be accumulated enough to make
a full coin and that would cause
inflation so much so that in the 1200s
as you know uh the Jews of of England
were expelled because of this concern
that they were behind this coin clipping
Scandal and uh and yet this was solved
by a physicist essentially um who had a
day job you know coming up with Calculus
and gravitation Etc so trust issues go
way back I I don't know that this is uh
this is going to go
away I agree so um the other thing that
I found uh you know provocative about
this book is that you you talk uh about
the opportunities and you talk about um
how we can use uh sort of a type of risk
management approach to to solve some of
these vexing problems and I guess you
know first of all my my question to you
is you know we look at something like
climate change which you speak very
vociferously about in this book and
convincingly we'll always have different
approaches to complex problems and I
don't think there's a single solution
but um what is it uh you know in your
mind that we would do if you were
Emperor Lord Martin re you know Lord in
the the Darth Vader sense what would you
enact if you could to start to address
this issue because let me just preface
this by saying I find it very um
depressing when we say you know there's
no solution we have to cut off
everything now and I remind people that
back in 1800s do you know what the worst
problem is that threatened the financial
industry on Wall Street in America Mar
it was the problem of of horse manure
that was gathering on Wall Street and
preventing Traders from going and and
pedaling their stocks and so that was
solved right it didn't involve you know
making putting horses on a diet or you
know putting diapers on horses uh it was
solved by technology name the car and I
wonder you know do we not hamper our
children in the imagination of future
Generations by saying we just have to
cut out what we're doing now and and not
really think so much about maybe you
know big risky things that could have
huge rewards so where do you come down
if you could if you could by Fiat uh
Implement changes what what would you
start with well I if we talk about
climates then I think the answer has to
lie in new technology I mean I would
have thought most people agree with that
um um politicians won't gain much
resonance if they uh promote a sort of
hair shirt policy that people have to
deny things but uh I I think uh um with
new new technology uh then uh I think it
is possible for us to move towards a
system where we can provide affordable
carbon free energy for the world and we
ought to prioritize this and um I've
been arguing this certainly in Britain
um uh in in Britain um we're a small
country and we produce less than 2% of
the world's CO2 emissions so if we uh
achieve our declared Target of zero net
carbon by 2050 that only make 2%
difference to the world right but I
would claim that um our country has had
more than 2% of the world's clever ideas
over the last few years and uh if we um
had a huge investment in um in in clean
energy and energy storage batteries and
all these things uh so that we could
make it easier and more affordable for
say India and Africa to Leap Frog
directed to clean energy then we make
far more than 2% difference to World CO2
emissions because of course um um the US
and and us we can probably cut
our um energy needs by fact of two
without any great hardship whereas
country like India and Africa they're
going to have to expand their energy
needs to have any decent standard of
living um and so um not only is the
population growing very fast there but
the per capital consumption is going to
be higher so the most important thing is
to ensure that those countries which
need need to
develop can do so in a carbon free way
and that can be done if the technology
is available and so we should help them
by we I mean the advanced countries like
the US and UK um we should help them by
um investing very heavily in the
development of all the things we need
for clean energy and I would include
nuclear in this as well so I think
that's that's the way to do it and it's
hard to think of more inspiring goal for
young engineers than to provide clean
and affordable energy not just for rich
countries but so that um India and
Africa can develop a better standard of
living so that that's the line I take
and incidentally um a similar argument
applies to food um because there'll be
nine billion people in the world by 2050
and um they certainly can't all eat as
much beef as present day Americans it's
got to be a slightly different diet um
remind I'm late for a barbecue so we
should Hur just kidding and and so um
we've got to have high-tech agriculture
sustainably intens farming of vegetables
and also artificial meat that's a great
technology and been advances just the
week we're speaking um the um artificial
meat for American companies being
approved in Singapore officially this
first step forward and these
Technologies are important so I'm saying
that the techically advanced countries
um can develop benign Technologies in
order to provide carbon free energy and
enough food for nine billion people in
the world by 2050 so that's the argument
I would give I did do an interview with
an author of a book uh Chase pery with
an who wrote the book called billion
dooll Burger about the quest to produce
lab grown meat and uh prices come down
from a billion dollars yeah they're
they're still quite High I want to
finish up uh in the the few minutes that
we do have left if you have a few more
minutes Lord Martin i' very much
appreciate it h i want to ask I'm
talking with Leonard mad now who spent a
lot of time at Cambridge working with
your late colleague uh Stephen Hawking
and uh he talks a lot in in his most
recent book which is kind of like a
biography of of Stephen Hawkings
friendship with Leonard Milan now and uh
I wonder you know in terms of the
Partnerships that you've had with
remarkable people uh I want to get to
Lord uh rabbi Jonathan Sachs who passed
away as well in a minute but but first
with stepen Hawking the kind of you know
collegiality is I think one or at least
um you know coming together uh has been
lost in coid it it is possible to save
you know on traveling for a colloquium
but it's not possible to have the same
colloquial kind of interactions and I
wonder if that in your mind is going to
change you know briskly with the Advent
of a vaccine or is this going to
permanently affect science and in my
opinion a very negative way the all the
authors I've written about and you as
well talk about your most you know kind
of uh delightful moments are with
colleagues so will that be permanently
uh ratcheted down as we go forward I
worry very much about this and uh I
think it's true that you know people
like us can probably travel less when
it's just for a meeting or something
like that but uh thinking back to my own
career I benefited hugely from being
able as a postto to um um visit the main
centers in the US and to get to know my
contemporaries around the world and also
have a chance to talk informally to
senior people now if you're postto and
is a big Zoom conference then you may
get your 10-minute slot but you get no
feedback and you get no chance to chat
informally to senior people so I think
whatever we do uh if we're in charge of
research group we've got to make sure
that the young people can travel in the
way they used to I mean the old people
who already have the contacts uh can
probably um do their work remotely if
you know people already but the young
people need to have the real contacts
and I think otherwise I would share your
concerns very much indeed and when we
think about um colleagues outside of our
own academic uh sort of Silo um yes you
must have known uh Rabbi Lord J Jonathan
saaks who passed away can you say
something about him uh and what you know
your relationship might have been like
as as as Lords I didn't know him well I
mean I've read some his books and I
heard him talk and uh uh you he was a
very very clear speaker uh there's one
thing I found found very hard to
reconcile about him which was his sort
of um General sort of ecumenical style
in general combined with his very
austere intolerance style doing his job
as Chief Rabbi it was a famous case when
he refused to go to the funeral of a
more liberal Rabbi who was a national
figure it was a scandal at the time so I
couldn't understand how how he combined
uh um his General views with uh being
rather sort of intolerant um uh in his
role as Chief Rabbi so that was my
perplexity I had about him he of course
died very suddenly uh just just about a
month and a half ago surprising he was
um he was only in his just over 70 I
think wasn't he yeah I think he was 72
very vibrant and he still his children
and his foundation carry on his
important work one thing he was known
for that I do uh note that you are
participating in as well is social media
and actually you have a Twitter account
if I'm not mistaken which I'll link to
in this um I've had conversations with
people last six months yes yes yes it's
delightful and I I do uh no Facebook no
no what up yeah and I will I will put
that uh on in the show notes for this
episode so people can follow you and uh
but I've spoken with eminent scientist
Paul steinhardt comes to mind where he
views it as a very pernicious element
Lenny suskin feels the same way way that
it almost is um it it almost is kind of
um detrimental in the fact that it may
stymy and stifle new ideas imagine
you're you're coming up with this idea
for CNB polarization in 1968 and you're
you're giving a lecture and and you know
Fred hoy's there Jeff Burbage is there
or they're not there but they tweet out
oh look at this crazy
idea um I mean do you think of it as on
the scientific front obviously in kind
of politics or whatever we could we
could take or leave it but you believe
it has a net beneficial uh effect for
scientific progress or do you think it's
detrimental well I think more outside
science I think it's definely
detrimental I think to uh um I think
social media um they hollow out the
center and they amplify exams which is
the reverse of what we used to have when
we had all the news filtered through
responsible journalists so it's bad but
in in science um I think I'm ambivalent
I mean it can do harm but I think um and
again this is a aspect of what I was
saying earlier about Academia becoming
less attractive I mean if people are
sort of constrained that the only thing
that matters is writing a paper in a
learned Journal um and they will write a
few papers per year and that's it you
know I think that's pity I think we far
better if there was far more blogging
and interaction and people got credit
for writing good blogs and um uh um
inventing new courses and things like
that um I think it's unhealthy that in
Academia the
the refereed paper is the only thing
that counts I mean I agree that there's
a risk of um lowering lowering standards
if you um value these other things too
much you've got to make clear that it's
a different aspect of one's life but I
think to actually encourage people who
um spread and popularize their science
widely and engage with these issues um
it can be done I mean for instance um in
my college in Trinity um uh Tim gaers
who's one of the world's leading
mathematicians he's had a very effective
blog and um he's done two things um
first he led the campaign against El sea
you know the commercial Publishers
ripping off academics with the cost of
journals uh and but also he um got a
theorem that was proved collectively you
know we talked at the beginning about
math being something which is done in a
solitary way but he had some idea of a
theorem that hadn't been proved and he
got this proved by a contribut about 70
different people on on his uh on his
blog and website and so to encourage
people to do that and try and make
science of social activity is good and I
think the social activ SS are what are
most attractive for me I mean uh I've
enjoyed having collaborators being in a
place where ideas are buzzing Etc it
becomes a bit solitary if you have to
work just on one narrow theme so um the
interaction is very very important one
thing that's uh very prevalent on social
media now are the presence of artificial
intelligent Bots and I want to ask you
about artificial intelligence uh but
maybe a question out of left field your
feelings on the Nobel Prize are welln at
least to me uh you criticized my book
not in your blurb thank God but you
criticized my my book and you you said
to me something like you wish I focused
more on the cosmology and not at all on
the Nobel Prize uh but I want to ask you
pertinent to artificial intelligence um
what do you think are the chances that
an artificial intelligence could either
win an Noel Prize or create something
that would be perceived in physics uh of
being Nobel worthy I think we had to
just recently the um protein folding
success of the Deep Mind people and
that's example and uh I think it's quite
likely that uh um if string theory is
the correct
Theory we may only learn
that through an AI having worked through
the complicated 10-dimensional geometry
so you can well imagine that um the
geometry could be coded in such a way
that the computer with the advant of
speed could explore all the options just
in the way it's done with protein
folding and uh as I said earlier on
we'll only know that the theory is
correct if it spews out the right mass
of the proton or strength of gravity Etc
um but it's quite conceivable to me that
a theory like string theory involves
very very complicated mathematics which
no human being can do in a lifetime but
which nonetheless could be solved by the
um by by a machine and uh so um that
doesn't mean you give them a prize but
they um they are would be an aid without
which the work would not have been done
so I think that's completely on the
cards very good okay I want to finish up
with questions that I ask of all my uh
guests who come on the show and they are
um really centered around big questions
final questions that in some sense do uh
hearken back to Sir Arthur C Clark the
namesake of the center that I co-direct
did you know Sir Arthur I forgot I
didn't I exchanged emails with him
actually about the jet of m87 and
whether was artificial um but uh I have
emails but I never actually met
but but his profiles of the future of
course which is the book we're
celebrating um was a big influence on me
yes yeah we have designs to update that
uh for the future and if so we will
include you I am of that I have no doubt
uh well we'll get to Sir Arthur's uh
influence on the final questions after
this first question uh which I Ask of
all my guests and that involves
something in Hebrew it's called an
ethical will a Zava and it it is related
in some sense to Alfred Nobel who gave
away his material Goods but he also had
this kind of heterodox component that
the winners benefit mankind uh and that
is non-material immaterial and sort of
ethical in nature and I want to ask you
uh if you were to put uh something in
your ethical will not your material will
and that undoubtedly uh your material
will undoubtedly contains nothing but
blockchain and Bitcoin uh after today's
conversation uh but I want to know what
would you offer in terms of Wis
or values for not only your biological
Offspring but your ideological offspring
of which I count myself as one going
back to my concerns expressed in the
book we've been talking about um I would
say we've got to realize uh that uh the
inequalities in the world need to be
reduced there's inequality within
countries um and inequalities between
the wealthy Northern parts of the world
and and Africa and other parts we won't
have have a a peaceful world unless
those are diminished and so I think any
money I was able to leave Etc would go
towards those those causes to reducing
inequalities because it's an ethical
indictment that the wealth of the two
million richest people in the world
could double income the bottom billion
is not happening I wonder you know
because you do mention that and you
mention the you know income inequality
or in or just wealth inequality do you
have a practical way to to to you know
to administer that you know for example
I look at there's um Michael Atherton
was a star Cricket player and he's known
for I don't know how do you say it
hitting many centuries or I I don't
follow Cricket if you can't tell but
never very wealthy and I I just wonder
how how would we do it we have Short
Stops in America that make a hundred
times what I make as a university
professor and they're not even that good
uh so how do you go about doing that how
do you distribute income how would you
do it again as Lord of Empire of of of
the planet not just of the British
Empire well it's accepted that it's
getting worse and that the uh the top
0.1% has been is the only segment of the
population in the US which is better off
in real terms than 20 years ago I think
this is true so something is in my view
going very wrong and it's almost as bad
in my country and uh I I think the um
the tax system could do something about
this very good I don't believe anyone
needs such a huge to keep them working
so the next one question I asked my
guest does relate to Sir Arthur C Clark
and that is connected to the movie 2001
A Space Odyssey where these uh PR uh
primates or hominids on The Plains of
the Savannah of Africa come upon this
enormous monolith are you familiar with
that scene I am yes yeah so then and
then later on it's and they don't know
what to do with it so they hit it with a
bone or you know something which makes
me hungry for for the barbecue that I'm
missing but uh but then later on it
makes an appearance on the Moon in space
Etc and it's clear it's meant to
represent some sort of a time capsule
something that humans are meant to
encounter when and only when they are
able to benefit from the wisdom or the
knowledge or the or something contained
within and you talk a lot in this book
about potential cataclysms uh that could
occur and I want to remind you what uh
Fineman said a so-call cataclysm
question he said if in some cataclysm
all of scientific knowledge were to be
destroyed and only one sentence passed
on to the next generation of creatures
what statement would contain the most
information in the fewest words and so
he gave an answer about atoms containing
you know being the building blocks of
everything I want to ask you what would
you put on your monolith a billion year
lasting Time Capsule that encapsulates
maybe all of science or all of your
accumulated wisdom perhaps well I think
fin answer is the one I would give I
mean that that's that's the best but I
think to
um to phas sightly differently
if if you ask me um what uh I've changed
in my views about from being young to
being pretty ancient now um it's to to
um become more amazed at the mystery and
wonder and complexity of the universe
and and the world especially biological
world because um you know most people
you look at insect or something flying
around and they're common things but but
if you just think of when the insect
flapped its wings once
all the series of chemical reactions
that have to go on and how it's got to
find out then the amazing complexity in
even what we think of a very humble
manifest of nature um I I don't think
when I was young I appreciated that I
don't think most people do I think if
you think about animals and plants you
you don't realize that um if you think
about them in the way that thon's
recommending which is in terms
of really basically chemistry it's
amazing the intricacy that's involved
and so uh I'm more and more amazed at
the complexity and uh wonder and mystery
of even simple things yeah me too I I
think about that often when I think back
to when I was younger something sad
would make me cry or make me emotional
and nowadays it's much more likely to be
something good or beautiful as you just
mentioned that you know especially
having children Etc that brings me to
the state of emotion because it's so
precarious unlikely un entropically
favored that we experience goodness and
I think the pandemic has taught me that
reinforced me that uh notion even more
so to appreciate the the Grandeur and
the beauty of the world of course we
always have to balance that against the
tendency to worship nature the guia
hypothesis Etc um but I thought it was
interesting I interviewed uh andrean
this summer uh the Widow of the late
great Carl Sean who endorsed your book
as well uh she's a writer and producer
of of and director of Cosmos and she
talked about your ability to be as a
prophet essentially as a prophecy being
a lost art but no better person than you
to take a multi multi-dimensional
meditation of one of our most
distinguished and wise scientific Minds
I couldn't agree with that more and
remind me to tell you her I asked her
what would you put on a billion year
lasting Time Capsule and she said you
mean what did I put on a billion year
lasting Time Capsule because she yes
yeah she recorded her w yeah for the
Voyager one uh Golden Disc so-called
Golden Disc I thought that was amazing I
had the honor of giving the uh the first
Carl Sega Memorial lecture at Cornell
who set up for the Carl Sean Center and
and she was there to share it this was
three years ago oh wonderful yes and her
daughter has recently become an author
and wrote a book for small creatures
such as we and I had both of them on the
show at different times so my first
mother daughter uh guest appearances on
the into the impossible podcast that's a
quite uh I call them the first family of
the cosmos no no pun inent they're great
in fact I remember I first met them when
they were doing the first Cosmos series
in the about 1980 wasn't it yes to
Cambridge there and I was already there
wow yes I would have loved to to have
gotten to know Carl uh unfortunately
there aren't many of them as you point
out uh he was unique almost maybe
there's one other person uh but speaking
of one other thing I want to bring up
the last of the three questions which is
Sir Arthur C Clark had these many laws
and one of which which we open the show
with is an actual recording of his voice
saying the only uh any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic so that was his some people
say it's a second law I don't really
care I call it his first law his second
law is um for every expert there's an
equal and opposite expert which I I have
found to be uh true in some context and
uh and the last law is the only way to
discover the limits of the possible is
to venture a little bit beyond them into
the impossible and you hinted at this
before but I want to ask you just just
in summary what thing about life or
science mystified you as a as a young
person a 20-year-old Martin before you
were a lord um that you would give
advice to and what would that advice be
uh to your former self to go a little
bit into the impossible what would you
tell a younger version of yourself in
terms of Life advice well I think what I
would tell any S is to pick a topic
where new things are happening new
observations new techniques more path
computers um so you can do things the
old guy's never had a chance to do
otherwise You' be getting stuck on the
things they try to do and fail so you've
got to go into a subject that's changing
fast and uh if I were to predict what
that's going to be um it's going to be
the the interface of computing and uh
biology and astronomy and I I would
encourage them to think about um uh
alien life what might be out there and
of course one one of the most exciting
areas in science of course as you know
is exoplanet research in 10 years we
probably know if there's a biosphere on
some of them and uh you might learn
something even more exciting so I would
encourage people to work in a field
where there's new techniques new
understanding and that's uh as Carl
would
working on if he was still alive one of
the most exciting ones absolutely well
Lord Martin Reese I want to thank you so
much uh for taking time out of your very
busy schedule uh you mentioned to me uh
in passing uh that you're working on
another book is that true yes well I'm
doing two one is going to be a sort of
self-facing autobiography I'm going to
sort of talk talk about the big problems
of science including the ones we haven't
yet solved but try and uh um human it
not with my own story which is very
boring but by talking about some of the
um eminent scientists I've had a chance
to meet oh wonderful start with da and
going on to you know Freeman dce and and
many many others so I think I can
personalize it because I've been lucky
to have a chance to meet and learn from
a lot of those people so I'm doing that
I'm was doing another rather boring book
on the organization of Science and uh um
how we've got to make sure that science
still provides a vibrant career for
young people and how research should be
organized and how universities should be
changed and all that so that's a sort of
bureaucratic book I'm writing I would
love to help out in any way possible
you've been a huge influence on me
personally as a as a as a man as a as a
human being but as a scientist as well
uh anything I could do to ever uh to
help you out please do let me know and I
can't wait to read the autobiography
just don't be like Charles barklay the
famous NBA basketball player in America
who said he was taken out of context and
misquoted in his autobiography I I hope
that doesn't happen to you Lord re thank
you so much for going into the
impossible and I look forward to talking
to you when your next book comes out and
I hope you will discover the priority of
gravitational waves I'll do my best I'll
do my best thank you Lord uh Lord Mar I
want to encourage my guest to follow uh
Lord Martin on Twitter he is Lord uh
Lord Martin Reese I believe on Twitter
let me just look that up yes Lord Martin
Reese Lord Martin Ree he also has many
many books as we've discussed I want to
ask you all to encourage you all I
should say to please leave a rating and
a review on iTunes of of this podcast
into the impossible subscribe and share
it with your friends so we can get more
great guests we're going to have uh Ray
Weiss on the podcast in the next few
weeks Joe Dunley who is a a fellow
member of the royal British Empire
something like that she's coming on soon
giant narar I already mentioned and then
we have John preskill coming up in the
new year and many many other great
guests I'm trying to get AI presc is
into a AI Now isn't he he is he is he's
into Ai and Quantum uh quantum
entanglement all sorts of things he's
he's he's spent the money he got from
the bet with Hawking very wisely and
we'll talk about that uh as Roger
Penrose says you know no matter what
side of a bet you took with Stephen
Hawking you could always be sure of
winning it because he Chang his mind so
much uh but we'll have on Len Leonard
madno as well who wrote the biog
biography of friendship with Steven
Hawking and many many other great guests
coming up uh and I want to thank once
again Lord Martin Ree have a wonderful
rest of your night and please be in
touch about your next book I can't wait
to read it